[Music]
there was a time when the fierce and
beautiful land of allegation Erica
narration also allegations more like a
skin cream than a place where people
would choose to live a young writer
named Galbatorix betrayed them I was
with these goddamn names what happened
to simpler fantasy names such as Bilbo
Gandalf or Luke just want to point out
that even in 2006 there were video games
that look better than this
the fucking Eragon video game didn't
look much worse than this he crushed all
rebellion including the freedom fighters
known as the Varden king our story
begins one night sorry chief your story
began when you started talking and that
was almost two minutes ago we're going
to see the story or just hear it because
that's what audiobooks are for we're
sorry here I suffer without my stun do
not prolong my suffering is definitely
phoning this one in but are you
surprised this guy was in Conair if
Durza can make fire appear wherever
then why wouldn't he just make it appear
in the place Aria is currently standing
in coincidence he's out here nights
shooting arrows at deer when this
ancient whatever decides to leave a
memory egg stone thing right here and
now from the guy who wrote Jurassic Park
3 the decision to make this dragon egg
look like a blueberry Mike and Ike seems
misguided not Daisy Ridley because this
movie is old enough Daisy Ridley would
have been a child but this chick still
looks like Daisy Ridley and it's kind of
weird sort of looks like Daisy Ridley I
have something something to trade this
mother for on is about to trade a dragon
egg for some cold cuts and I'm offended
the scene didn't come with any white
wine I sound effects or a hilarious
oversized hook dragging him off screen
between this and Assassin's Creed and
Dungeons & Dragons want us to wonder if
Jeremy Irons has to fantasy films what
Jai Courtney is two franchises I think I
think you're a thief a poacher i
confiscate them all in the name of the
king I mean it domain oh hell Eragon the
mighty hunter returned with his
invisible catch since roarin was back at
the homestead sleeping in well Eragon
was at least trying to hunt them some
dinner maybe you should quit being such
a dick be roaring this goes on for some
time I'd take a hundred sins off right
here and now if this egg bursts open and
he found a good movie inside knocking
Eric on I guess this is as good a time
as any to roll the fucking credits
Ronin is telling Eragon he's leaving to
avoid being drafted into the army but
Aragon's face says I don't have to do
all this pink farm work on my own
goddamn it what many men seek is often
right on
then knows this is the medieval fantasy
version of wherever you go there you are
sister was in a great hurry when she
left here besides I'd she not I wouldn't
have gained another son broken homes are
amusing well look at the convenient
timing of the hatching this fucking egg
would you he only just found it so
dragon is about to hatch and suddenly I
realize this movie is basically a
discount kind of How to Train Your
Dragon why is it okay this movie with
Malkovich Rachel Weisz Djimon Honsou
Robert Carlyle and Jeremy Irons spent
all its money on casting and ignored
everything else most noticeably the
story and the special effects and it
shows if he had this trick up his sleeve
why wait until now to use it sure the
egg hatching just happened but the
vision of Eragon holding the egg was
from the previous day when the Varden
learned that the legend is real they
will be encouraged to challenge me
considering it seems like Galbatorix
only has one employee I'm surprised they
haven't challenged him already and I
don't care how powerful a sorcerer Durza
is yes to sleep at some point where's
Yuma did she abandon you team heavy hand
is heavy can kids know this thing's cute
must resist moving that was close that's
supposed to be an actual place or a
painting in my dentist's office
did he just create an army out of dirt
bat sauna Dragon Riders come again
prophesies the scene of teaching the
dragon to fly was originally set to Tom
Petty's learning to fly but too much of
the budget went to casting so they
turned to Lenny Kravitz who had yet to
fully come into hungergames money then
he gave them the empty pockets routine
and also asked for too much money so
ultimately they just demanded the
composers score the scene for no extra
pay I'd give good money if the Sean
Connery dragon from dragon heart showed
up and ate this tiny dragon in a single
bite and then turned to the camera
declaring my loss wrong one good way to
keep this under wraps is to let the
dragon fly around so everyone can see
her not gonna lie I forgot about the
hand burn thing and never assumed prior
that it was magically connected to
something but mostly I'm looking at this
shot wondering what the fuck is wrong
with Aragon's middle finger it's not
only not the longest finger on his hand
it's actually smaller than the two
fingers neighboring it he has a human
hand but a hobbits middle finger he's
still looking at his hand holy
did this dragon just literally aged up
four years in a single 30-second flight
I thought the Lion King log was some
bull I have waited a thousand years to
hear your thoughts
dragon stalking candle candle candle
candle candle candle candle candle
candle yeah who
how's prom cells I always say better ask
forgiveness than permission should have
been this movies fucking tagline they
killed captain purples and he served his
purpose in the movie already so
hopefully no one will miss it uncle go
away this movie's Encino man moment
rings hollow both because we know that
will reconcile soon and because the
actor playing Eragon is terrible in
acting who are you he's clearly a
discount Aragon Aragon duh also
considering how much exposition Brom has
given so far in the film it's odd he
can't answer a simple question that's
the spirit
fun pop brave three pots full and all
party moving
Raza killed mesons Ra'zac the nazgl
called and the witch Kane wants a word
bitches Givaudan
so this movie is starting so hard Percy
Jackson just decided to sue them all so
eloquent exposition exercise between Eko
islands eviscerates every attempt
employed toward equanimity Sara can you
find us
I never left you Facebook muscular
graceful proportions talons nice thick
legs a bit thin john lasseter meet the
dragon Levada need a rider if they had
to defeat desert and the king a rider
will live on that is dragonis kills but
if a rider dies
this movie is 43% rules not Saruman
shows up to check on the nut orcs
progress and can I go home now go home
no I don't want to be here I know I said
I'd finish the whole thing but now I
just want to go home her goals in the
rock instead of nazgul in the arc I
Jesus instead of Aragon you should have
just called the Xerox hey everyone come
quick lucky Morpheus is fighting lucky
neo also why do so many movie mentors
take such gleeful pleasure in hurting
and embarrassing their students Batman
Begins Matrix Karate Kid there's a clear
pattern to teach a lesson this guy
threatens to drop Eragon into a creek
that is 3 inches deep
couldn't the movie have filmed this on a
real cliff and have him dangle dude over
a huge drop into a raging river you're
gonna have the threat dangle moment why
set the scene at a bend and Bob's
backyard Creek but then a lot tomorrow
by the end of the
we will slip through doubt it unseen
blah blabbity blabbity blah blah horse
riding on a beach horse riding on the
terrain we riding on the moors relieve
the horses here keeps a fear of closed
Saphira even hiding this well she's a
giant fucking dragon I mean we're not on
Godzilla hiding in Manhattan levels but
we're pretty fucking close you have been
long awaited by many races really
because to me he just seems like a kid
who was in the woods one day and an egg
appeared roar and I've been the one
hunting and found the egg wouldn't he be
in the scenario or what if Sloane had
traded the piece of state for the egg
earlier seems to me Eragon was just in
the right place at the right time
he yells Brisingr here and it makes his
arrows do amazing man he seemed to go he
saw her Jeremy's irons a bruising her to
his fire starting kit and flame up here
my point is why in the name of any kind
of common sense would Eragon think in
this moment of life or death to shout
the word the creepy guy once said back
in the forest the power Brisingr is so
strong it makes Eragon pass out after
saying a word one time magic comes from
dragons but how magic must be a last
resort he why though before you cast a
spell you must learn the ancient
language of the elves
he's already cast a pretty massive spell
so check your grammar dawg
he can't never if he's already ever know
the word and you control the thing know
the word and you control the thing this
is some discount Mike Brady version of
obi-wan other spells if you use them
before your Reggie will kill you great
thankfully I have months to study right
not so bad at all the bad guys give the
good guys time for this it feels like
this movie should spend a lot less time
on these bonding and training scenes and
a lot more time on developing Galbatorix
as a villain we should give two shits
about Eragon defeating
bran think Eragon can hear him is there
gonna actually becoming a better writer
here it's a serious question
I'm zero clue whether this is supposed
to be considered a success and I doubt
any of the other viewers do eat oh is he
keeping pace with them that's one of the
biggest movie lines ever man this guy
Ennis Lightspeed horses exactly how did
Eragon to know how to activate his
predator vision and why that's riding a
dragon give you predator vision several
seconds of an apparent fight scene
edited by someone at gunpoint who would
be shot if they didn't finish before the
roller coaster stopped your
irresponsibility and it costs Saphira
her life she's a sentient dragon dude
she said with pleasure when he told her
to die let's spread the blame around a
little bit here can we
dump dough who the am I kidding that's
not a surprise
he feels exactly like what it is a hasty
low-budget adaptation of a post Lord of
the Rings movies fantasy novel written
by a 15 year old kid where's your giant
dad well I should definitely keep
listening to you about how to train my
dragon right bring me the boy my son
bring me his blood actually you said
these have semantics angry bad guy kills
a henchman to show the other henchmen
and the audience that he's super serious
about his orders being followed and
seeing as mission completed CLE shit
congratulations you've just been
promoted angry bad guy that just killed
a main henchman to make a point then
declares another nearby random normy
henchman to be the new hench leader
cliche I tire of this I'll bring the boy
to me well fan oh so why'd you keep
sending henchmen in the first place to
do a job that was that important
Hangouts movie is filled with so many
moments of why the didn't you just do
that in the first place
oh he's dreaming about a Lindsey
Stirling video why are you going to find
oh yeah the girl from your dream
immediately that's the thought no wait
see you movie was basically doing some
kind of wackadoo twist on the pronoun
game with this Vardhan alternatively
using it as the name of a place and the
name of a people what it means to be a
dragon rider and hiragana knows all
about it after saddling up for all of 10
minutes well Sam I guess we need to find
a way into that what's that let's know
Sam in this movie not even a goblin
guess I'm on my own hold dad well today
not for us because I had a dream about
it no one will be seated during the
return of the Jedi portion of the movie
not mom he's learned a ton of magic
spells off-camera and it's frustrating I
knew you were young but even then I
expected someone a little more well more
you and me both babe let's drag an ex
machina doubles the ex machina power of
the seats like Mario eating a powerup
mushroom and then immediately eating a
fireball flower as well
can you carry three not very long Goff
you pussy
your ginormous I suggest you leave
quickly how many ex mocking us did you
write into the scene like oh also oh
good let's introduce Garrett Hedlund now
that there's only like half an hour left
in the movie guess we'll learn more
about him in the sequels sequels
seems like that would have been good
info for Aragon to have before they
entered the castle please hey how does
he know all these spells well at least
you guys aren't trying to hide or
anything I've seen a lot of dumb things
in movies I've watched everything
transformers movie more than once and
I'm king went to opening night to watch
a movie with carrot top
but somehow Jerry irons having a death
scene while riding a dragon might be the
dumbest shade has poisoned her I feel
like I should care but since I know
nothing about this character other than
she transported a Dragon's egg what
seems like 10 hours ago I just don't
need to get you to the votive how do I
find why not just give him directions
this mystical is infuriating dude is
leading Eragon to a place he can't find
on his own but Eragon is literally in
the lead and every single one of these
travelling b-roll shots will have to go
by foot yeah the horses could never man
into this perfectly flat section of
trail Oh boss I've been captured by the
faith militant sons of the upside-down
cereal bowl hats Without Borders of all
the luck
the task was simple bring the boy to me
oh great another the task was simple
seen also the boy was literally here in
very recently so technically Durza did
his job this is really on Galbatorix at
this point also its capital works like
the master on Buffy the Vampire Slayer
can he not leave this one area because
this is the only place we've ever seen
him in the entire movie as long as I am
king disloyalty will be punishable by
death this is the most do we've all
moving ever not directed by Louie bolt
and the dragon walks off to make sure
Arya gets medical attention and all I
can think of is thank God this network
of caves is comprised of all caves tall
wide long enough to accommodate a
goddamn ginormous dragon he is the son
of Morrison the traitor
don't-don't-don't wait who was that
again son doesn't choose his father true
but kim jeong-hoon can say the same
thing I've no time to take chances maybe
but you also need all the help you can
get so maybe give Murtagh at least one
chance my name I'm just a farm boy from
Kabul you mispronounced tatooine I need
to know so soon why me
you choose a leader for his heart great
as long earlier you told me she was too
young to breathe fire and that was like
maybe a couple of weeks ago she should
not be breathing fire right now except
for plot convenience also how did she
not just roast the fuck out Erica I mean
he's standing literally right there in
the fires path swords arrows fire
your turn the favor to the CGI company
by not billing them for the scene that
ultimately looks vacant discount all the
things goddammit this movie rips off so
many other better movies I'm just adding
40 cents for the audacity of it all doc
magic oh it's so dark and full of bad
CGI I can't tell what's happening I
already know who wins we're literally
just wasting everyone's stars I'm losing
strength thing I said twenty minutes
into the film somehow makes it into the
climactic dialogue they both survived
this crash landing that would have
crippled the Starship Enterprise
try to avenge this defeat you guys
thought while making this thing that you
were gonna get to make a second one and
that's hilarious it's easy to make jokes
about this movie it's pretty terrible
and ignored a lot of what made the
source material popular but in case you
were worried there were no consequences
this is the only movie that its director
has ever directed someone gave him his
shot on this movie and he stepped in it
a little bit and he hasn't ever directed
a feature since that's damaged I feel
bad for the guys I'm honest this movies
process and our reception ended this
guy's directing career no movie is so
bad its director should be barred from
ever trying again
well no movie except Maximum Overdrive
[Music]
I don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating as you might have heard we
recently announced the inaugural year of
sin week it's coming up soon polish sin
week is an e convention that you can
access at all levels of patreon it will
have five cinemasins videos that we for
members panels a live podcast and much
more
and if you're signed up at the top tier
you're eligible to attend sin week
in-person hang out with Chris Jeremy and
the sins gang in beautiful Nashville
Tennessee you'll be digging up a top
golf you'll even be treated to some
great food from if you haven't already
sign up today at patreon.com slash
cinemasins
join the club we Baraka
the Kings animus now that he's God
did you pierce in through the heart once
again things that could have been
brought to my attention
yes you know nothing Jon Snow as I was
going to sometimes I met a man with
seven wives every wife had seven sacks
every sack had seven cats every counter
said my kid was mean ones count sacks
and wives how many were going cousin
times I will merely confine myself to
remark that a no will be regarded as a
declaration of war too bad we can't stay
baby flesh down gently I've seen things
you could never imagine I have seen
that'll turn you white